لا يزال لدينا الكثير من الأسئلة الليلة
حول هذا الفيديو الذي ظهر أه
يبدو أنه يُظهر رجالًا فلسطينيين وطفلين على
الأقل في ملعب بغزة
يتم تجريدهم من ملابسهم الداخلية أه
واحتجازهم من قبل جنود جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
الآن أه لقد حددنا الموقع الجغرافي
للفيديو  نحن نعرف أين تم التقاطها ولكن
لا يمكننا التحقق بشكل مستقل عندما
حدث هذا بالفعل تم نشرها
عشية عيد الميلاد أه في الماضي إسرائيل
قالت أن سبب ضرب
الناس هو فحصهم بحثًا عن
متفجرات أه وحتى إسرائيل تقول
خلال آخر مرة  لمدة أسبوع تقريبًا أثناء
تنقلهم من منزل إلى منزل في غزة،
عثروا على مخبأ للأسلحة بما في ذلك سترات
ناسفة تقول إسرائيل إنها
معدلة ليرتديها الأطفال لكننا
ما زلنا نطرح أسئلة حول أه بالضبط
ما هي الظروف أه مع هذا
الفيديو الذي  يظهر هؤلاء الأطفال أه ولكن
هناك الكثير من مقاطع الفيديو المروعة الأخرى
التي تخرج من غزة